يمكن أن يكون اتباع أوامر البقاء في المنزل أمرًا
معقدًا خاصة بالنسبة للمؤمنين
حيث نتجه إلى ما هو أحد
أقدس الأسابيع للمسيحيين واليهود
على حد سواء ، فكيف يمكنك التجمع في هذه
الأحداث المقدسة في أحد الشعانين من عيد الفصح بعيد
الفصح عندما لا يمكنك التجمع من أجل  من
أجل صحة الجميع ، لا أعتقد
أن الحكومة لديها السلطة
لإغلاق كنيسة ، فأنا بالتأكيد
لن أفعل ذلك ، وأعتقد أنه سيأتي بشكل خاص
في موسم عيد الفصح ،
أعتقد أن الناس سيرغبون في الوصول
إلى الكنيسة كما تعلمون  الخدمات الدينية سواء كانت على
الإنترنت سواء كانت
في نوع خدمة أكثر بعدًا اجتماعيًا من أصل
42 ولاية مع أوامر البقاء في المنزل
موقعة من قبل المحافظين ، 14 منها تقدم
إعفاءات لأماكن العبادة أو
المؤسسات الدينية ، وغالبًا ما
تتضمن إرشادات تشجع على
الخدمات  يتم إجراؤها عبر الإنترنت ، وعلى سبيل المثال في
تكساس ، يقول المدعي العام إنه إذا
حدثت التجمعات شخصيًا ، فيجب عليهم
اتباع إرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي الخاصة بمراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها ،
لكن معظمهم يظلون في الولايات الأصلية  عدم
إجراء استثناءات مع كل الاحترام الواجب
، من الضروري أن نمارس التباعد الجسدي في
كل مكان ، حيث يقول المسؤولون الصحيون
في مقاطعة ساكرامنتو بكاليفورنيا
إن 71 شخصًا مصابًا
بفيروس كورونا مرتبطون بالكنيسة نفسها ،
وهي جماعة يحضرها العديد
من أعضاء المجتمع الناطقين بالروسية.
أغلقت الكنيسة أبوابها في
18 مارس ، لكن وزارة الصحة
تعتقد أن الفيروس لا يزال ينتشر
خلال اجتماعات الزمالة في منازل الناس في
جميع أنحاء العالم الذين يمارسون
الدين مثل أي شيء آخر
يتحول بشكل متزايد إلى عمل منعزل
حتى لو كان في وحدة روحية في أوائل
مارس المملكة العربية السعودية مؤقتًا  تعليق
السفر لأداء العمرة على مدار العام
إلى مكة والمدينة
لأول مرة في التاريخ الحديث.
إحياء
التقاليد النظامية العديد من بحارة هذا الأسبوع
وستُعقد الجماهير
بطريقة غير تقليدية إلى حد بعيد حيث
يناقش اللامو أمانو المدينة فقط - سنحتفل سانتا
بالأسبوع المقدس
بطريقة غير عادية حقًا تُظهر
وتلخص رسالة الإنجيل التي
تتمثل في حب الله اللامحدود وفي صمت
مدننا سوف يتردد صدى إنجيل عيد الفصح
ناتاشا تشين سي إن إن أتلانتا